Shannon let's talk about where the Main
Street economy meets the sharing economy
Walmart saying they're going to use uber
and lyft to make deliveries now yes some
big grocery news for them today and a
really a way to fortify this wall around
their grocery business in spite of
companies like Amazon and Google all
trying to get into the grocery business
they're going to launch a new service in
two cities where a goober or lyft driver
will pick up your groceries that you
purchase online from a Walmart store
deliver them to your home the companies
also really been pushing new technology
around ordering groceries online and
picking them up in the store and we can
expect the CEO to talk a lot more about
that to all the shareholders gathering
behind me here today yeah Shannon how
much of this is not just about Walmart
but about Amazon and how they can
actually compete with Amazon taking a
bigger and bigger chunk of that core
business that they've always had I think
almost everything Walmart does at this
point has something to do with Amazon
and of course don't forget every other
retailer like Target that's trying to
push more online too they were a step
behind on Amazon when Amazon came in
with general merchandise electronics
books toys they're not going to let that
happen to their grocery bill business at
least they hope half of their business
comes to grocery so that's why it's so
important from them